we have got to vote for joe biden like
our lives
depend on it joe biden has michelle
obama's vote
150 percent i am
here tonight because i love this country
with all my heart
and it pains me to see so many people
hurting
the former first lady wore her heart on
her sleeve at this year's virtual
democratic national convention
delivering an impassioned speech
praising the former vice president
i know joe he is a profoundly
decent man guided by faith
he was a terrific vice president he
knows what it takes to rescue
an economy beat back a pandemic and lead
our country michelle said joe is a man
who
listens and promised the american people
that if he's elected president
he will tell the truth and trust science
he will make smart plans and manage a
good team
and he will govern as someone who's
lived a life that the rest of us can
recognize
michelle spent two terms in the white
house with her husband
former president barack obama she said
she's seen
firsthand what's required for the job
and
it's not easy it requires clear-headed
judgment
a mastery of complex and competing
issues
a devotion to facts and history a moral
compass
and an ability to listen
and an abiding belief
that each of the 330 million lives in
this
country has meaning and worth
you simply cannot fake your way through
this job
as for what the former flotus thinks of
president donald trump's time in office
she didn't sugarcoat it whenever we look
to this white house for some leadership
or consolation or any semblance of
steadiness
what we get instead is chaos division
and a total and utter lack of empathy
it is not a hard concept to grasp but
right now
kids in this country are seeing what
happens when we
stop requiring empathy of one another
and just in case that wasn't clear
enough she doubled down on all of that
and said it quite bluntly donald trump
is the wrong president for our country
he has
had more than enough time to prove that
he can do the job but he
is clearly in over his head he cannot
meet this moment
he simply cannot be who we need him to
be
for us it is what it is
the 56 year old becoming author went on
to say she knows her message will go
unheard by so many but regardless
she implores americans to get out and
vote on election day
she even rocked a gold necklace that
spelled out that special four-letter
word
if you think things cannot possibly get
worse
trust me they can and they will if we
don't make a change in this
election if we have any hope of ending
this chaos
we have got to vote for joe biden like
our lives
depend on it following her speech stars
were quick to hit up social media to
react
i'm very very proud of it ellen pompeo
tweeted quote
michelle obama that's it that's the
tweet
bette midler gave her a standing ovation
viola davis said michelle was speaking
truth to power
octavia spencer explained that the
speech had her feeling hopeful
and kerry washington said the whole
thing was so inspiring
mark ruffalo praised michelle for being
so direct
and empathetic while mandy moore said
michelle was forever
her first lady